Các có sở và lựa ý của Mỹ tại ý róc những ngày gần đây, liên tiếp khứng chiếm nhiều bụt tấn công khi xung độ giữa liên quan Mỹ Israan và Iran đã bước sẵn quần thứ 3 liên tiếp,
làm giới lên lòng ngày róc bị quần sau hơn vào cùng khoảng cuối gực.
Cú thể ngày bị bụt thông ba, 2 con trước ăn những ý róc cho biết,
một tên lửa đã đánh trúng bại đã trực thăng trong khoảng viên đại xử quần Mỹ tại Bada.
Thế ngành tuyển trường cho thấy cuộc khỏi bốc lên từ khu phức ợp ngoại giao này,
sẵn chờ có bên nào nhận chắc nghiệp vụ tấn công.
Vụ việc giản ra sau hàng lox sự của giám vào các cơ sở liên quan đến Mỹ tại Iraq,
kể từ khi trên sự tại Trung Đông Bung Phát,
trước đó một mại bại không người loại đảnh trúng một cơ sở ngoại giao Mỹ tại Iraq,
trong khi loc cách các suy亞 cũng tình giám vào khu phức đại xe quán Mỹ vào mình bởi thăm ba.
Một số các cơ có sự gian diện của lực lượng Mỹ bao gồm khu vực gần sở bay Bada,
và thành phố A-Bin ở mình bác Iraq cũng tưởng vị tấn công vàng tên lửa vào quà vệ trong ngày gần đây.
Đặc biệt một sự việc vệ trong vòng đó là một câu trở như liệu thuộc sở hiểu Mỹ,
nhé hãy càng khó Anzu Wei,
mình đã bị rọc bị hai xuống không người lại mà trên lỗi tấn công.
Vong ngày 12 tháng 12, khi một thủy thu tên mạng.
Trong một dịch biến khám,
uống đổi Mỹ ngày 12 tháng 12,
cho biết một mại bây tếp dầu cà sê một bán năm,
đã anzu ý tại miền tay Iraq, khiến sảo quân nhân thình mạng.
Tuy nhiên, giờ chúng Mỹ khẳng định,
vụ việc này không lên quan đến hoa lực lưỡi phương.